I've never been interested in William Burroughs. You know who this is? Beat writer, author of Junkie and Naked Lunch . To me, it's like he was somebody glorifying and fetishizing heroin. He was into grand pronouncements, like--
我从未对威廉·伯勒斯产生过兴趣。你知道他是谁吗？“垮掉派”作家，《瘾君子》和《裸体午餐》的作者。对我来说，他就像是个美化和迷恋海洛因的人。他喜欢发表宏论，比如——
Nobody seems to ask the question what words actually are and exactly their relationship to the human nervous system.
似乎没人会去问：文字到底是什么？它们与人类神经系统之间究竟有着怎样的关系？
He just wasn't my thing. I didn't see what the big deal was. His ideas didn't seem interesting. I knew there were lots of really smart people who love him. I did not get it.
他就是不对我的胃口。我不明白他有什么了不起。他的想法看起来一点也不吸引人。我知道有很多非常聪明的人都很崇拜他。但我就是无法理解。
And then I heard this radio documentary about him. And there's no other way to say this. I got it. I saw why people go nuts for him. The documentary was made last year to commemorate Burroughs' 100th birthday, commissioned by BBC Radio.
后来，我听了一档关于他的广播纪录片。我只能这么说：我懂了。我明白为什么人们为他疯狂了。这部纪录片是去年制作的，由BBC广播公司委托，为了纪念伯勒斯诞辰100周年。
And first of all, the sheer craft of this documentary was just a thing to behold-- finding people who knew Burroughs, and sorting through archival sound, and has this beautiful structure. But what really won me over is that it is not reverential about Burroughs. It thoroughly explains why he is such a mythic revered figure. But it doesn't buy into the myth.
首先，这部纪录片的精湛技艺本身就令人叹为观止——寻访认识伯勒斯的人，整理档案录音，而且结构设计非常优美。但真正征服我的是，它对伯勒斯并没有盲目崇拜。它彻底解释了为什么他是一位如此神话般受人尊崇的人物，但它并没有全然接受那个神话。
And they do this totally untraditional kind of narration where the rock star, Iggy Pop, who is apparently a huge Burroughs fan, both narrates the show and comments on the narration that the show producer has written to the show producer all through the show. I have never heard anything like it. It's one of the best hours of radio I heard last year, and one of the most original.
而且他们采用了一种完全非传统的叙事方式，让摇滚巨星伊基·波普（Iggy Pop）——他显然是伯勒斯的超级粉丝——不仅担任节目旁白，还在节目全程中对制作人撰写的旁白内容进行评论。我从没听过这样的节目。这是我去年听过的最好的广播节目之一，也是最有创意的一个。
Burroughs' 101st birthday is this week. And to commemorate it, I'm going to play you this documentary. OK? It's going to happen right now. So from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And without further delay, I hand this over to producer Colin McNulty and his presenter. They're Brits. That's the word they use presenter, for the narrator. His presenter, Iggy Pop. Heads up, there are some impolite words in here and one racist term. If you're listening to this by podcast or over the internet, you will be hearing these words without beeps.
本周是伯勒斯诞辰101周年。为了纪念他，我将播放这部纪录片。好吗？马上就要开始了。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。废话不多说，现在就交给制作人科林·麦克纳尔蒂（Colin McNulty）和他的主持人。他们是英国人，他们用“主持人”（presenter）这个词来称呼旁白。他的主持人是伊基·波普。事先提醒一下，这里面有一些不雅用词和一个种族歧视词汇。如果你是通过播客或网络收听，你听到的这些词不会经过消音处理。
And we've also included a few full sentences here with sexual content that had to be cut from the American broadcast of the episode. If you are somebody who prefers a less explicit version of the show-- maybe you have kids wandering in and out as you listen-- you can get that at our website, thisamericanlife.org. British radio, as you're about to hear, is more permissive than American radio when it comes to sexual content. Though they did begin their broadcast of the show with their version of a listener advisory, not like ours at all.
我们还在此保留了几个被美国电台版删减的、涉及性内容的完整句子。如果你倾向于收听不太露骨的版本——比如你听节目时家里有孩子走来走去——你可以去我们的网站thisamericanlife.org获取。如你即将听到的，英国广播电台在性内容方面比美国广播电台更开放。尽管他们确实用他们自己的方式在节目开头发布了收听提醒，这和我们那一套完全不同。
A warning. The following program contains references to homosexuality, drug use, sex with aliens, violence, and kitty cats. What did you expect?
警告：以下节目包含有关同性恋、毒品使用、与外星人发生性关系、暴力和猫咪的内容。你还期待什么呢？
[LAUGHS]
（笑声）
[KNOCKING]
（敲门声）
Iggy.
伊基。
Hey, how you doing?
嘿，你好吗？
Good, how you doing?
很好，你呢？
You were casing the joint.
你刚才在侦察现场。
I was, sorry.
是的，抱歉。
Not at all.
没关系。
I was afraid I'd get lost.
我怕我会迷路。
Well, and you were going to be punctual, right?
嗯，而且你本来打算准时的，对吧？
Yeah, exactly.
是的，没错。
Sit down, please, for a little bit.
请坐一会儿。
OK, cool. What are we doing?
好的，酷。我们要做什么？
This is William Burroughs' 100th birthday, and we are taking a look at his life, his times, and his work. I didn't write this stuff, but I'm willing to present. All right?
今天是威廉·伯勒斯诞辰100周年，我们要回顾他的人生、时代和作品。这些稿子不是我写的，但我愿意担任主持。好吗？
That's fine, man.
没问题，哥们。
I will really hope you put that line in there.
我真希望你把那句台词加进去。
I didn't write this stuff.
这些稿子不是我写的。
I'm not that close to the take of BBC4 or this whole thing. I'm going to be honest with you. Presenter? To me, I feel like I should have a little hat. Hey, ladies and gentlemen, are you ready for star time? Ready to rumble. I could do those voices. At this particular time, we'd like to introduce the star of the show, Colin McNulty. All right, let's go.
我对BBC4台或者整个事情并不太了解。老实说，主持人？我觉得我应该戴顶小帽子。嘿，女士们先生们，准备好迎接巨星时刻了吗？准备好躁起来了。我能模仿那些声音。在这个特别的时间，我们要介绍本节目的主角，科林·麦克纳尔蒂。好了，我们开始吧。
Let's do it.
开始吧。
You ready?
准备好了吗？
I'm ready.
我准备好了。
Now I've met William Burroughs once, and have been inspired by him, but I am not an expert on Burroughs, unlike this guy.
我见过威廉·伯勒斯一次，也受过他的启发，但我不是伯勒斯专家，不像这位仁兄。
I'm Oliver Harris. I'm a professor of American literature. I'm the author and editor of 10 books on or about William Burroughs. The strange thing is that a million people who never heard of William Burroughs can sing lines from The Ticket That Exploded, and that's because Burroughs' book is where Iggy Pop found the raw materials of Lust for Life.
我是奥利弗·哈里斯（Oliver Harris）。我是美国文学教授。我写过或编辑过10本关于威廉·伯勒斯的书。奇怪的是，有一百万人甚至没听说过威廉·伯勒斯，却能背诵《爆炸的票据》（The Ticket That Exploded）里的台词，那是因为伊基·波普就是从伯勒斯的书里找到了《Lust for Life》的创作素材。
It's where Johnny Ann comes from, along with those hypnotizing chickens and the flesh gimmick and the strip tease and the torture film. Pop responded to the way Burroughs was working back in the 1960s in a kind of montage way that we now take for granted in a digital era, but Burroughs was pioneering it.
书里有约翰尼·安（Johnny Ann），还有那些催眠鸡、肉体噱头、脱衣舞和暴力电影。波普对伯勒斯在20世纪60年代那种蒙太奇式的创作方式产生了共鸣，这种方式在数字时代我们已习以为常，但当时伯勒斯是先驱。
This is coming out of some Lust for Life , all right. He's not just in my music. Burroughs is everywhere. He's in Dylan's Tombstone Blues. He's on the cover of Sergeant Pepper's two rows behind Paul, right next to Marilyn Monroe.
这来自《Lust for Life》，没错。他不仅出现在我的音乐里。伯勒斯无处不在。他在迪伦的《Tombstone Blues》里。他在《Sergeant Pepper's》专辑封面上，保罗身后两排，就在玛丽莲·梦露旁边。
He inspired band names like the Soft Machine, a great band, and Steely Dan, which is named after a strap-on dildo in Naked Lunch. I didn't know that. The world was introduced to the phrase "heavy metal" in the book Nova Express.
他启发了乐队名称，比如“软机器”（Soft Machine），一支伟大的乐队，还有“史帝利·丹”（Steely Dan），这个名字源于《裸体午餐》里的一种穿戴式假阳具。我当时不知道。世界是在《新星快车》（Nova Express）这本书里第一次接触到“重金属”（heavy metal）这个词的。
He worked with Kurt Cobain on a spoken word track, The Priest, They Called Him. Fight tuberculosis, folks. As Lou Reed said, without William, there is nothing.
他曾与库尔特·柯本（Kurt Cobain）合作过一首口语录音曲目《The Priest, They Called Him》。对抗结核病吧，伙计们。正如卢·里德（Lou Reed）所说，没有威廉，什么都没有。
I am writing for people who are interested in exploring unexplored psychic areas.
我为那些有兴趣探索未开发精神领域的人写作。
This month, it has been 100 years since the birth of William Seward Burroughs II. By the time he died, the man left behind a humongous body of work. Bear with us. It's going to get weird. There will be drugs, sex, violence, aliens, the beats, of course, Tangiers, Paris, New York, and cats.
这个月，是威廉·苏厄德·伯勒斯二世（William Seward Burroughs II）诞辰100周年。在他去世时，这位作家留下了一大批惊人的作品。请耐心听着，内容会变得很怪。会有毒品、性、暴力、外星人，当然还有“垮掉派”、丹吉尔、巴黎、纽约，以及猫。
We'll play around with cut ups too, but that will be explained. We've trawled through Burroughs' work and the archives, particularly Burroughs, The Movie , a film directed by Howard Brookner, which is being rereleased later this year. We've also spoken to many people that have been permanently touched by William Burroughs.
我们也会玩玩“剪接法”（cut-ups），但稍后会解释。我们查阅了伯勒斯的作品和档案，特别是霍华德·布鲁克纳（Howard Brookner）导演的《伯勒斯电影》（Burroughs, The Movie），该片将于今年晚些时候重新发行。我们还采访了许多深受威廉·伯勒斯影响的人。
I'm looking at my little collection here. I have the book Queer by William Burroughs. And it's autographed, "To John Waters, with admiration and friendship, William Burroughs, November 3, 1985 at the Mary Boone gallery."
我正在看我的小收藏。我有威廉·伯勒斯写的《同性恋者》（Queer）。上面有签名：“致约翰·沃特斯（John Waters），带着钦佩和友谊，威廉·伯勒斯，1985年11月3日，于玛丽·布恩画廊。”
Exhibit A, director John Waters. Burroughs gave him a name that stuck, The Pope of Trash.
证据A，导演约翰·沃特斯。伯勒斯给了他一个响亮的称号：垃圾教皇（The Pope of Trash）。
Yes, I've been shamelessly milking that title, The Pope of Trash, for years. Matter of fact, as I'm sitting here, I'm wearing a long cloak to the floor and an imperial marjoram crown that says "The Pope of Trash" on it as we speak. But I grew up reading William Burroughs. I mean, I went to Catholic school and sat there and read Junkie , and the Christian brothers were so stupid, they had never heard of William Burroughs and thought, isn't it nice? He's reading. But they had no idea what I was reading.
是的，多年来我一直厚颜无耻地利用“垃圾教皇”这个头衔。事实上，我现在坐在这里时，正穿着一件拖地长袍，戴着一顶印有“垃圾教皇”字样的帝国马郁兰王冠。但我是在阅读威廉·伯勒斯的过程中长大的。我的意思是，我在天主教学校读书，坐在那儿读《瘾君子》，那些修士太蠢了，他们从没听说过威廉·伯勒斯，还想：多好啊，他在读书。但他们根本不知道我在读什么。
He was a role model for all of us. We all grew up reading him. When we were in high school, when we were stuck in suburbia somewhere trying to get away, we read him, and he ignited our imaginations. He let us dare to try something that we had been told we should never do. He was a bad guardian angel that got us out of the house.
他是我们所有人的榜样。我们都是读着他的书长大的。当我们还在高中，被困在某个郊区想逃离的时候，我们读他，他点燃了我们的想象力。他让我们敢于去尝试那些被告知永远不该做的事。他是一个带我们离家出走的坏守护天使。
But besides the writing, Burroughs the man is legendary. His hobbies, his personality, the way he lived his life became mythic. He was conformist America's dark nemesis.
但除了写作，伯勒斯本人也是个传奇。他的爱好、他的个性，他生活的方式都成了神话。他是传统美国社会黑暗的死敌。
The mugwump slips the noose over the boy's head and tightens the knot--
马格沃普人（mugwump）把绞索套在男孩脖子上并拉紧了绳结——
He wrote graphically about sex.
他用文字生动地描写性。
Moves in behind the boy and shoves his cock up the boy's ass. He stands there, moving in circular gyrations.
移动到男孩身后，把他的阳具塞进男孩的屁股里。他站在那里，做着圆周运动。
He was openly gay.
他是公开的同性恋。
We are a precarious minority. We've got to fight for our lives. If they're opposed, the gay state, we're going to find him, track him down, and kill him.
我们是一个岌岌可危的少数群体。我们必须为生命而战。如果他们反对，那个同性恋国家，我们会找到他，追踪他，杀了他。
I think Burroughs was the first militant gay person really that would dare to say that. So even the other beatniks were scared of him, I think. I think William out-hipped all of them, really, because he was so alarming and so scary and so macabre.
我认为伯勒斯是第一个真正敢于那样说的同性恋激进分子。所以，我认为即使是其他“垮掉派”也被他吓到了。我觉得威廉比他们所有人都更超前，因为他如此令人震惊、恐怖且阴森。
Well, I would use any weapons at my disposal in order to defend my premises.
嗯，我会使用我能动用的一切武器来捍卫我的立场。
Despite having shot his wife, Burroughs was obsessed with guns and weapons.
尽管曾射杀过妻子，伯勒斯却对枪支和武器着迷。
You had a razor sharp, double edge knife. You could whip it out and cut someone's throat before he knew what was happening. I'm not anticipating any trouble, because I don't like violence.
你有一把剃刀般锋利的双刃刀。你可以把它掏出来，在对方反应过来之前割断他的喉咙。我不打算惹麻烦，因为我不喜欢暴力。
And he was a heroin addict.
而且他是个海洛因瘾君子。
The whole drug problem started when they made drugs illegal.
整个毒品问题始于他们将毒品定为非法的时候。
He slid the needle in. A red organ bloomed at the bottom of the dropper, watching the solution rush into the boy's veins, sucked by silent thirst of blood.
他把针头滑入。一个红色的器官在滴管底部绽放，看着药液涌入男孩的静脉，被血液无声的渴求吸走。
I mean, he was everything. He took drugs. He was gay. He did things that no one dared mention, especially together, because gay people were kind of square then, the ones that people knew about. So he was a junkie gay person, which really caused a lot of trouble-- and unashamed.
我的意思是，他什么都占了。他吸毒，他是同性恋。他做了没人敢提的事，尤其还是放在一起提，因为那时的同性恋者在人们眼中还挺古板的，至少大众知道的那部分是。所以他是个吸毒的同性恋，这确实惹了不少麻烦——而且他毫不掩饰。
The mythic Burroughs was an old man in a three piece suit with this nasal voice rising up like this, railing against the world with one hand on the typewriter and the other pushing a needle into his arm. I can do him pretty good.
神话中的伯勒斯是一个穿着三件套西装的老人，有着那种鼻音，就像这样，一只手放在打字机上，另一只手把针头推入手臂，抨击着这个世界。我模仿他模仿得挺像的。
Yeah, you do a damn good Burroughs impression.
没错，你模仿伯勒斯模仿得真绝。
I only shot heroin once in my life, because I had to, in respect of William Burroughs. I mean, that's a terrible thing to say. But I did try it once. And you shouldn't because you can get hepatitis C from trying it just once. I don't have it, but I know people that do. William Burroughs was a bad influence on me. And I thank him for that.
我这辈子只打过一次海洛因，因为出于对威廉·伯勒斯的尊重，我必须这么做。我的意思是，这话真糟糕。但我确实试过一次。你不应该试，因为哪怕只试一次也可能感染丙肝。我没有，但我认识有的人。威廉·伯勒斯对我来说是个坏榜样。我感谢他这一点。
But not everyone appreciates the Burroughs myth.
但并非所有人都欣赏伯勒斯的传说。
I don't just take the Burroughs myth with a pinch of salt. I view it as a unpleasant slug crawling across the lawn of literature. And I like to pour salt on it.
我不只是对伯勒斯的传说半信半疑。我把它视为一条爬过文学草坪的令人不快的蛞蝓。我喜欢往它身上撒盐。
The writer, Will Self.
作家威尔·塞尔夫（Will Self）。
Do you like his stuff? You said you did.
你喜欢他的作品吗？你刚才说你喜欢。
I told you I did, yeah, yeah. Known smart ass.
我告诉过你我喜欢，是的，是的。这家伙是个自以为是的聪明鬼。
When I was at school, I got the English prize when I was 16. And I asked for a copy of The Naked Lunch . I used to have it with the sort of school coat of arms on a book plate in the front of it.
我上学的时候，16岁那年获得了英语奖。我要求奖品是一本《裸体午餐》。我曾拥有过它，书的前页还有学校的校徽书签。
Having used heroin yourself--
你自己也吸过海洛因——
I think used is a bit of an understatement. I was a heroin addict on and off for pushing a quarter of a century. For myself, I find the whole Burroughs myth pretty repulsive, actually. Because I understand what happened to me. I was an addict in waiting. I got my form prize or my English prize at The Naked Lunch. And a year and a half later, I was sticking needles in my arm.
我觉得用“吸过”这个词有点轻描淡写了。我断断续续当了近四分之一个世纪的海洛因瘾君子。对我自己来说，我发现整个伯勒斯的传说其实非常令人反感。因为我了解我身上发生过什么。我是一个候补瘾君子。我拿了我的英语奖品《裸体午餐》。一年半后，我就在手臂上扎针了。
Was it that direct for you?
这对你来说有那么直接吗？
Well, I'm not saying it made me do it. I'm saying that my attraction to Burroughs' work was very much to do with the mythos, and particularly to do with the mythos that surrounded him because of being a heroin addict. And that's the point about Burroughs, is that he exists. You could be lying in some pestilential piss-soaked squat in the bowels of the city listening to some moron totaled on drugs drooling on and talking about Burroughs, because Burroughs was their Leon Trotsky. He was their Archbishop of Canterbury. He was the Pope. I'd rather belong to the priesthood than be with the guy who was lying on the carpet drooling about-- that's all. That's all there is to it, though.
我不是说书让我那么做的。我是说，我对伯勒斯作品的吸引力很大程度上与那种神话感有关，特别是与他作为海洛因瘾君子所带来的那种神话感有关。而这正是伯勒斯的关键所在，他的存在。你可能躺在城市深处某个充满尿骚味的腐烂贫民窟里，听着某个嗑药嗑到神志不清的白痴流着口水谈论伯勒斯，因为伯勒斯是他们的列昂·托洛茨基。他是他们的坎特伯雷大主教。他是教皇。我宁愿属于那个教派，也不愿和那个躺在地毯上流着口水胡言乱语的人在一起——就这样。仅此而已。
One day Burroughs found himself in the possession of some morphine syringes, and he tried junk for the first time.
有一天，伯勒斯发现自己有一些吗啡注射器，他第一次尝试了毒品。
Morphine hits the backs of the legs first, then the back of the neck, a spinning wave of relaxation, slackening the muscles away from the bone so that you see the bloat without outlines.
吗啡先击中双腿后部，然后是颈后，一股旋转的放松感，使肌肉从骨骼上松弛下来，让你看到没有轮廓的肿胀。
I became addicted to drugs before I'd written anything. And actually, my first book, Junkie, was simply an account of my experiences.
我在写任何东西之前就对毒品上瘾了。事实上，我的第一本书《瘾君子》仅仅是我经历的记录。
I think it was medicine for the dude. It's painful. It's painful to be a human being. I'm not even half anymore. I can't take it. I've never been more than half at one time.
我觉得这对那家伙来说是药。那很痛苦。做人很痛苦。我再也不完整了。我承受不了。我从没试过一次性拥有超过一半的自己。
I think that his genius, in as much as he has any-- and you see it in ample evidence in Junkie -- is that he makes of the condition of the addict a synecdoche for the condition of everybody.
我认为他的天才之处在于——只要他有天才的话，你在《瘾君子》中就能看到充分证据——他把瘾君子的状况作为所有人状况的代名词。
There are all sorts of things you can get out of this guy's books without having to be interested in whatever he thought about opiates.
你可以在这个家伙的书里得到各种各样的东西，而不必对他的鸦片观点感兴趣。
I think the way to read Junkie is not as a book about heroin addiction at all. It's a book about the condition of modern man that developed capitalistic societies.
我觉得解读《瘾君子》的方式根本不是将其视为一本关于海洛因成瘾的书。它是一本关于发达资本主义社会中现代人状况的书。
William was on and off junk for the rest of his life. His addiction followed and pushed him everywhere. Flash forward to Burroughs living in his New York home, the bunker.
威廉余生都在断断续续地吸毒。他的成瘾史追随并推动着他四处漂泊。快进到伯勒斯住在纽约的家中，那个被称为“碉堡”（the bunker）的地方。
Yeah, I saw Bill take junk. It almost seemed like someone had put a junk supermarket right smack in the middle of the punk world to destroy them.
是的，我见过比尔（Bill）吸毒。这几乎就像有人把一个毒品超市直接开在朋克世界的正中央，为了摧毁他们。
Writer and biographer, Victor Bockris.
作家兼传记作者，维克多·博克里斯（Victor Bockris）。
Everyone had a copy of Junkie . They read them over and over again, but they didn't seem to get the real message of it because they seemed to think it was really cool to take heroin with William Burroughs.
每个人都有一本《瘾君子》。他们读了一遍又一遍，但似乎没能领会真正的深意，因为他们似乎觉得和威廉·伯勒斯一起吸海洛因真的很酷。
Hi, there. Colin, are we going to tape?
嗨。科林，我们要开始录音了吗？
James Grauerholz was Burroughs' friend and manager for over 20 years.
詹姆斯·格劳尔霍兹（James Grauerholz）是伯勒斯的朋友兼经纪人，共事超过20年。
Every time we went to New York, I saw a slightly out of control scene. Running the bank accounts, I could see it flowing out of the ATM down the street from the bunker. He was looking for a pastoral retreat, and I was looking to lure him to it for his sake to get him away from all the young wannabe hipsters ringing the buzzer of the bunker, breaking out the baggies of dope, and saying, hey, I brought you a gift.
每次我们去纽约，我都看到一个稍微失控的场景。管理银行账户时，我能看到钱从“碉堡”街头的自动取款机里流出去。他在寻找一个田园式的隐居地，而我想为了他好，把他引到那里去，让他远离那些成天按着“碉堡”门铃、掏出小袋毒品说“嘿，我给你带了礼物”的年轻伪嬉皮士。
It was a very constructive move, and absolutely the right thing to do. At the time, of course, we were all really pissed off that Burroughs was leaving New York. But god, he thrived in Kansas. He really thrived out there.
这是一个非常有建设性的举动，绝对是正确的做法。当时，我们当然都对伯勒斯离开纽约感到非常生气。但天哪，他在堪萨斯州过得很好。他确实在那里茁壮成长。
I got him on methadone maintenance, and he remained on that until the end of his days, and it was very heightening for his productivity. And it needs to be difficult to see Burroughs, and it's not going to prevent people that deserve to see him from seeing him to make them come to Lawrence most times. After all, Voltaire lived 25 years in the tiny town of Ferney in Switzerland, and the crowned heads of Europe made their way to his estate.
我让他参加了美沙酮替代疗法，直到他生命尽头他一直维持着，这对他的创作力有很大的提升。要见到伯勒斯应该是有难度的，这不会阻止那些真正值得见他的人来看他，让他们多跑几次堪萨斯州的劳伦斯市。毕竟，伏尔泰在瑞士费内的小镇住了25年，欧洲的王室成员都亲自去他的庄园拜访他。
We'll leave Burroughs on his methadone program in Kansas for now. OK, where next? Outer space. Space! Space!
我们暂时让伯勒斯在堪萨斯的疗程中停留一下。好的，接下来去哪？外太空。太空！太空！
That's good. Can you just say outer space?
那很好。你能只说“外太空”吗？
Outer space.
外太空。
I am attempting to create a new mythology for the space age. I feel that the old mythologies are definitely broken down and are not adequate at the present time. The Nova mob, Sammy the butcher, green Tony.
我正试图为太空时代创造一种新的神话。我觉得旧的神话已经彻底崩溃，在当下已不再适用。新星暴徒，屠夫萨米，绿色托尼。
This is the Nova trilogy, told as only Burroughs could tell it. It depicts a space age war between the Nova police, the good guys, and the Nova mob, a band of aliens from outer space who want to enslave human beings through the virus power.
这就是新星三部曲，只有伯勒斯能讲出来的故事。它描述了太空时代的一场战争：新星警察（好人）与新星暴徒（一群来自外星的、想通过病毒力量奴役人类的外星人）之间的战斗。
This is science fiction, but it is science fiction in terms of what is actually here now. I have Nova conspiracies, Nova police, Nova criminals. The virus power manifests itself in many ways, in the construction of nuclear weapons. This is war to extermination. In practically all the existing political systems, which are aimed at curtailing inner freedom. The Earth is a slave planet. It manifests itself in the extreme drabness of everyday life in Western countries. Are these the words of the all-powerful boards, syndicates, cartels of the Earth? You must learn who and what the enemy is, their weapons and methods of operation.
这是科幻小说，但这是关于当下的科幻小说。我有新星阴谋、新星警察、新星罪犯。病毒力量在许多方面表现出来，比如核武器的制造。这是一场灭绝之战。在几乎所有现有的政治系统中，其目的都是为了限制内心自由。地球是一颗奴隶行星。它表现为西方国家日常生活中极度的沉闷。这些是地球上那些全能的委员会、财团、垄断集团的言论吗？你必须了解谁是敌人以及敌人是什么，了解他们的武器和操作方法。
The alien enemy was in him.
外星敌人就在他体内。
Like Burroughs, that proud American name. The enemy is in you. Proud of what, exactly? Play it all, play it all, play it all back. Pay it all, pay it all, pay it all back.
像伯勒斯那样，那个引以为傲的美国名字。敌人就在你体内。对什么感到骄傲，到底？全部播放，全部播放，全部播放。全部偿还，全部偿还，全部偿还。
The key to Burroughs' obsession with power is in his own biography, his love/hate relationship with American culture, and his affluent Saint Louis upbringing.
伯勒斯对权力的痴迷关键在于他自己的传记，他与美国文化那种爱恨交织的关系，以及他在圣路易斯的富裕成长环境。
But before we look ahead, let's turn backward for a moment to consider how all this began.
但在展望之前，让我们先回头片刻，思考一下这一切是如何开始的。
This might surprise you.
这可能会让你感到惊讶。
It began with this, the world's first practical adding machine. William Seward Burroughs invested 10 years of his brief life in its development.
它始于这个，世界上第一台实用的加法机。威廉·苏厄德·伯勒斯在他短暂的生命中投入了10年时间进行研发。
William's namesake and grandfather invented the first mechanical adding machine. By 1920, the Burroughs Adding Machine company is worth over $400 million. Oliver Harris.
威廉同名同姓的祖父发明了第一台机械加法机。到1920年，伯勒斯加法机公司价值超过4亿美元。奥利弗·哈里斯。
Both sides of his family tied Burroughs to pioneering capitalists in business and military computing, as the Burroughs adding machine, and also public relations. His uncle, Poison Ivy Lee, was a press agent for Rockefeller and for Standard Oil. He also supposedly was going to work for Hitler, so he was your classic press agent with no values and no morals.
伯勒斯的家族双方都与商业和军事计算领域的开拓性资本家挂钩，比如伯勒斯加法机，还有公共关系。他的叔叔，“毒藤”李（Poison Ivy Lee）是洛克菲勒和标准石油公司的公关代理人。据说他甚至打算为希特勒工作，所以他是一个既没有价值观也没有道德底线的经典公关。
That's Burroughs' ancestors, capitalists and spin doctors.
这就是伯勒斯的祖先，资本家和舆论操纵者。
I think Burroughs reacted to that in his own work.
我认为伯勒斯在他的作品中对此做出了回应。
The type of people that would become his enemies.
那些会成为他敌人的人。
Are these the words of the all-powerful boards, syndicates, cartels of the Earth?
这些是地球上那些全能的委员会、财团、垄断集团的言论吗？
Burroughs put his privileged, haute bourgeois background, his classical education, to very good use by taking it back on itself. And that's really key to the work that came afterwards.
伯勒斯将他那享有特权的高等资产阶级背景和古典教育，很好地用在了反思自身上。这确实是他后来作品的关键。
I was born February 5, 1914 in Saint Louis, Missouri.
我出生于1914年2月5日，密苏里州圣路易斯。
Like Burroughs, that proud American name.
像伯勒斯那样，那个引以为傲的美国名字。
Now I never felt that I really belonged at all in the whole Saint Louis social structure. There was just something wrong there.
我从来没觉得我真正属于整个圣路易斯的社会结构。那里一定有什么地方不对劲。
Well, you can't mention Burroughs without mentioning the other members of the holy trinity. Beep beep. On the drums, William Burroughs. On bass, Allen Ginsberg. On the trumpet, Jack Kerouac. I won't do that again. They were a group Burroughs fit in with, pretty much.
嗯，提到伯勒斯就不能不提神圣三位一体的其他成员。嘟嘟。鼓手是威廉·伯勒斯。贝斯手是艾伦·金斯堡（Allen Ginsberg）。小号手是杰克·凯鲁亚克（Jack Kerouac）。我不会再那样做了。他们是一群伯勒斯能与之相处得来的人，基本如此。
Basically, he was a man without a mission at age 29, 30, when he met Allen Ginsberg and Jack Kerouac. They're portrayed as a merry band of artistic, smiling, laughing pranksters. They were all miserable. These guys 13 all the time. That's what I would say.
基本上，他在29、30岁遇到艾伦·金斯堡和杰克·凯鲁亚克时，是一个没有使命的男人。他们被描绘成一群快乐的艺术恶作剧者，总在微笑和大笑。他们都很痛苦。这些家伙一直都……我要说，他们总是很压抑。
Burroughs, Kerouac, and Ginsberg formed a triangular friendship that would become the heart of an entire literary movement. Allen Ginsberg. I had matzah ball soup once with Allen Ginsberg.
伯勒斯、凯鲁亚克和金斯堡形成了一种三角友谊，成为整个文学运动的心脏。艾伦·金斯堡。我曾和艾伦·金斯堡吃过一次丸子汤。
Did you?
真的吗？
It was possible to be gay without having to be ashamed of it in that generation in that community. Burroughs was gay. I was gay. Kerouac was straight.
在那个时代、那个圈子里，成为一名同性恋者而不必为此感到羞耻是可能的。伯勒斯是同性恋。我是同性恋。凯鲁亚克是异性恋。
It was a tolerant extended New York family, hell bent on personal freedom.
这是一个宽容的纽约大家庭，一心追求个人自由。
We began experimenting-- myself, Burroughs, Kerouac, and Hunky and others with Benzedrine inhalers. And those were kind of interesting.
我们开始实验——我自己、伯勒斯、凯鲁亚克和亨基等人用苯丙胺吸入剂。那些东西还挺有趣的。
While Burroughs was wallowing in drugs and young men in Tangier, the rest of the Beat generation was in full swing.
当伯勒斯在丹吉尔沉溺于毒品和少年时，其余的“垮掉派”正处于全盛时期。
There was no doubt about the Beat generation, at least the core of it, being a swinging group of new American men intent on joy.
毫无疑问，“垮掉派”一代，至少是核心成员，是一群追求快乐、充满活力的美国新青年。
Ginsberg's poem "Howl" was published in 1956.
金斯堡的诗歌《嚎叫》（Howl）出版于1956年。
I saw the best minds of my generation destroyed by madness.
我看见这一代最杰出的头脑毁于疯狂。
Kerouac's On the Road was published in 1957.
凯鲁亚克的《在路上》（On the Road）出版于1957年。
All that road going. Think of Dean Moriarty. I even think of old Dean Moriarty, the father we never found. Think of Dean Moriarty. I think of Dean Moriarty.
那一路的狂奔。想想迪恩·莫里亚蒂（Dean Moriarty）。我甚至想起老迪恩·莫里亚蒂，我们从未找到的父亲。想想迪恩·莫里亚蒂。我想到迪恩·莫里亚蒂。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Though Burroughs wouldn't consider himself a Beat writer, the three of them stuck together and supported each other's careers. By the late '50s, they were in Paris, keeping the bohemian theme going.
虽然伯勒斯不会自认为是“垮掉派”作家，但他们三人始终团结在一起，支持彼此的职业生涯。到50年代末，他们来到巴黎，继续保持着波西米亚风格。
I was one of the very rare Frenchman that they knew because I'm half American and I speak English.
我是他们认识的极少数法国人之一，因为我有一半美国血统，而且我说英语。
They met artist Jean-Jacques Lebel.
他们遇到了艺术家让-雅克·勒贝尔（Jean-Jacques Lebel）。
And I would take them around to North African bars, mostly to buy some hash and [INAUDIBLE].
我会带他们去北非酒吧，主要是为了买点大麻和（听不清）。
Their base would become known as the Beat Hotel.
他们的基地后来被称为“垮掉派旅馆”（Beat Hotel）。
It was a sort of paradise and hell at the same time. It was definitely the cheapest hotel in Paris. It wasn't very clean. And there was only one phone. So when Madame Rachou, the lady who was running the place, had to call Brian, for instance, she went out into the street and said, Brian, telephone! And he would put on his pants and run down. It was wonderful.
那是一个天堂和地狱并存的地方。这绝对是巴黎最便宜的旅馆。它不太干净。而且只有一部电话。所以当经营那里的拉舒太太（Madame Rachou）需要给布莱恩（Brian）打电话时，她会走到街上喊道：“布莱恩，电话！”然后他就会穿上裤子跑下来。那真是太棒了。
I'm David Delannet. I co-manage the bookstore Shakespeare and Company in Paris. What happened here is that very quickly, when this bookstore opened, it became a center for expatriates. They decided they'd do a reading here, especially for "Howl," in this room actually on the first floor of the bookstore, which is more like a lending library than a commercial space. And at the end of the reading, Burroughs did a reading of a work in progress, which was at the time the Naked Lunch.
我是大卫·德拉内（David Delannet）。我是巴黎莎士比亚书店的共同经理。发生在这里的事情是，书店开业后很快就成了侨民的中心。他们决定在这里朗诵，尤其是为了《嚎叫》，就在书店二楼的这个房间里，它更像是一个借阅图书馆，而不是商业空间。在朗诵会结束时，伯勒斯朗诵了一部正在创作的作品，当时就是《裸体午餐》。
I just want to rub up against you and get fixed. Ugh, well, all right, but why can't you just get physical like a human?
我只是想和你磨蹭一下，好解决问题。呃，好吧，但你为什么不能像个人类一样直接点？
Right, we're on sex.
好，我们现在讲到性了。
Yeah. Naked Lunch oozes sex. Seems like a good time to get libidinal.
是啊。《裸体午餐》里满是性。看起来是时候进入本能领域了。
He didn't start life with any insecurity about whether his desires were legitimate.
他的人生起点并没有任何关于其欲望是否合法的焦虑。
James Grauerholz.
詹姆斯·格劳尔霍兹。
So I'm sure it came as a great shock to him when he realized that his interest in other boys sexually was a great horror and either a crime or a sin, an illness, or all three.
所以我确信，当他意识到自己对其他男孩的性趣是一种极大的恐惧，要么是犯罪，要么是罪恶，要么是疾病，或者三者皆有时，对他来说是一个巨大的打击。
The spindly, sickly looking teenage Burroughs was sent to Los Alamos Ranch School in New Mexico.
那个瘦骨嶙峋、病态的少年伯勒斯被送到了新墨西哥州的洛斯阿拉莫斯牧场学校。
Where they later made the atom bomb. It seems so right, somehow, like the school song, far away and high on the mesa's crest. Here's the life that all of us love the best.
他们后来在那里制造了原子弹。这感觉很对劲，就像校歌里唱的，遥远而高耸在平顶山的顶峰。这是我们大家最爱的生活。
And in his diary, apparently, he entered his emotions and feelings and factual accounts of sexual contacts with at least one other boy at the ranch school. The boy with whom he had some involvement turned on him and outed him and pointed at him, and he became ostracized and black balled. He contacted his parents and got himself yanked out of school on some medical pretext within 48 hours. But his belongings didn't go home to Saint Louis with him. They had to be packed and shipped, including the diary.
显然，他在日记中记录了自己的情绪、感受以及与该牧场学校至少另一名男孩发生性关系的实情。那个与他有牵连的男孩背叛了他，揭露了他，指证了他，他因此被排挤和抵制。他联系了父母，并在48小时内以某种医学借口将自己接出了学校。但他的行李没能和他一起回圣路易斯。它们必须被打包运回，包括那本日记。
I used to turn cold, thinking maybe the boys are reading it aloud to each other. When the box finally arrived, I pried it open and threw everything out without even a glance at those appalling pages. That was to put me off writing for many years.
我以前一想到男孩们可能会大声朗读它，就会浑身发冷。当那个箱子最终到达时，我撬开它，甚至没看那些可怕的页面，就把所有东西都扔掉了。那件事让我很多年都失去了写作的念头。
And he never really tried to write again until 1950.
直到1950年，他才真正尝试再次写作。
After Harvard and medical school in Vienna, Burroughs ended up in New York and met his first boyfriend, who would loudly cheat on him while William listened through a thin wall. To retaliate, he cut off the top joint of his left little finger with poultry shears.
在哈佛和维也纳医学院学习后，伯勒斯最终到了纽约，遇到了他的第一个男朋友。当威廉隔着薄墙偷听时，对方对他大声出轨。为了报复，他用家禽剪刀剪掉了左手小指的指尖。
I think on Wikipedia, they say I'm widely acknowledged to be the last lover of William Burroughs. But I'm not-- I'm not sure what scholarship that's based on.
我觉得在维基百科上，他们说我被广泛公认为威廉·伯勒斯的最后一位爱人。但我——我不确定这种学术依据是什么。
In the late '80s, Burroughs met Marcus Ewert. He was 18. William was 74.
80年代末，伯勒斯遇到了马库斯·尤尔特（Marcus Ewert）。他18岁。威廉74岁。
So how much detail did you want?
那么你想知道多少细节？
Marcus met William in the bunker.
马库斯在“碉堡”遇见了威廉。
So I arrived at the bunker. It's like 2:00 or 3:00 in the afternoon. And William is showing me all these different things on his desk, like a scorpion and a paperweight and some old dented bullets that had some story attached to them. And then I was like, oh wait. He's nervous.
我到了“碉堡”。大约是下午2点或3点。威廉正在向我展示他桌上的各种东西，比如蝎子、镇纸和一些带着故事的旧凹陷子弹。然后我想，噢等等。他很紧张。
I think finally we sit on the edge of the bed. He's sitting about half a foot away from me, and we're not talking. It's very, very quiet. And then he moves his hand slowly onto my knee, and he takes the big leap.
我想最后我们坐在床边。他离我大概半英尺远，我们没说话。非常非常安静。然后他慢慢地把手伸向我的膝盖，他跨出了那一大步。
And then I reach over and put my hand on his knee. I give his knee a little squeeze. And then I threw my arm around him and kind of pulled him into me, like come here, you little William Burroughs, you. So at the very end of this sexual experience, the very first one in the bunker, he came. And I think I came too. And he said, "Oh, that was great. That was the first time that's happened in years."
然后我也伸手把手放在他的膝盖上。我轻轻挤了一下他的膝盖。然后我搂住他，把他拉向我，就像说“过来吧，你这个小威廉·伯勒斯”。所以在那次性经历的最后，在“碉堡”里的第一次，他高潮了。我想我也高潮了。他说：“噢，那太棒了。那是多年来第一次发生那种事。”
Marcus kept up the relationship in William's Kansas years.
马库斯在威廉的堪萨斯岁月里继续维持着这段关系。
We're getting into bed, and I'm sticking my legs down under the covers. There's this bump that my legs feel. And I'm like, "Oh, what's this hard thing my legs are bumping against, William?" And he said, "Oh, that's the gun." I said, "Is it a loaded gun?" He said, "Of course it's loaded." You'd sleep with a lover with a loaded gun in your bed. That's kind of a metaphor waiting to happen.
我们上床时，我把腿伸进被子里。我的腿感觉到一个凸起。我说：“噢，威廉，我的腿碰到这个硬东西是什么？”他说：“噢，那是枪。”我说：“那是上膛的枪吗？”他说：“当然是上膛的。”你会和一个上膛的枪躺在床上的爱人共眠。那真是一个随时可能发生的隐喻。
A hum of sex and commerce shakes the soul like a vast hive.
性和商业的嗡嗡声像巨大的蜂巢一样震动着灵魂。
Naked Lunch. Yeah.
《裸体午餐》。是的。
I had been occluded from space time like an eel's ass occludes when he stops eating on the way to Saragasso. The heat was on me from here on out, to a landlocked junk past where heroin is always $28 an ounce, and you can score for yen pox in the chink laundry of Sioux Falls.
我像鳗鱼停止进食前往马尾藻海时屁股闭合一样，被挡在了时空之外。热度从现在开始笼罩着我，前往一片没有海洛因永远是28美元一盎司的内陆垃圾之地，你可以在苏瀑市的中国洗衣店里为一点点毒资拼命。
A naked lunch, it sounds like a Gwyneth Paltrow cooking special.
“裸体午餐”，听起来像格温妮丝·帕特洛（Gwyneth Paltrow）的烹饪特辑。
I know.
我知道。
Yes I'm having a wonderful naked lunch with my children named after vegetables, and we're all so-- everything's beautiful. Pass the money.
是的，我和以蔬菜命名的孩子们正在享用一场美妙的裸体午餐，我们都如此……一切都很美好。把钱递过来。
Eventually, the book was Burroughs' biggest success.
最终，这本书成了伯勒斯最大的成功之作。
Naked Lunch . What better title could that be? Could you go into a store and say, "Excuse me, do you have Naked Lunch ?" No wonder it was a best seller.
《裸体午餐》。还有什么比这更好的标题吗？你能走进商店说：“不好意思，有《裸体午餐》吗？”难怪它成了畅销书。
In 1962, Naked Lunch was banned in Boston for obscenity, a decision that was reversed by the Massachusetts Supreme Court in '66. It was the last literary censorship trial in the United States. John Waters.
1962年，《裸体午餐》在波士顿因猥亵罪被禁，这一判决在1966年被马萨诸塞州最高法院推翻。这是美国最后一次文学审查审判。约翰·沃特斯。
And it got banned. That always really helped. And because it was experimental in the real sense of the word, it was hallucinary.
它被禁了。这总是真的有帮助。而且因为它在词义的真实意义上是实验性的，它是致幻的。
The brain, front, middle, and rear, must follow the adenoid, the wisdom tooth, the appendix.
大脑，前、中、后部，必须跟随腺样体、智齿、阑尾。
You know, people hadn't had hallucinations yet. They hadn't taken drugs. So they read this, and it was like, wow.
你知道，人们还没产生过幻觉。他们还没吸过毒。所以他们读到这个，就觉得：哇。
I give you my master work, the complete all-American deanxietized man.
我把我的杰作献给你，完整的、全美式脱焦虑的人。
And it scared people, and it delighted people, and it was like no other book anybody had ever written. And that always works.
它吓到了人们，也取悦了人们，它不像任何人写过的任何书。而这一招总是奏效。
The man wriggles. His flesh turns to a viscous, transparent jelly that drifts away in green mists, unveiling a monster black centipede.
那个人扭动着。他的肉变成了一种粘稠、透明的果冻，在绿色雾气中飘散，露出一只巨大的黑色蜈蚣。
Wait. We haven't even mentioned Joan yet. OK, it's time to talk about how Burroughs shot his wife.
等等。我们还没提到琼（Joan）呢。好吧，是时候谈谈伯勒斯是如何射杀他妻子的了。
My name is Kathleen Gray. I met William in 1974, and I knew him for 23 years.
我叫凯瑟琳·格雷（Kathleen Gray）。我1974年认识威廉，我认识了他23年。
In the '70s, artist Kathleen Gray invited Burroughs to give a talk in New Mexico. She asked him a couple questions.
70年代，艺术家凯瑟琳·格雷邀请伯勒斯在新墨西哥州进行一次演讲。她问了他几个问题。
What is your attitude towards women? And he said, "I killed the only woman I ever loved." We just stared at each other for possibly a full minute. Then he started to sob, and I just held him. And he was crying. And then he was whispering how much he loved her, how she'd actually saved his life on a couple of occasions. I don't know if there was ever an hour that went by without him thinking about it and his regret at what had happened.
“你对女性的态度是什么？”他说：“我杀了我唯一爱过的女人。”我们只是盯着对方看，可能有一整分钟。然后他开始啜泣，我就抱住他。他在哭。然后他低声说着他有多爱她，她曾在几次场合中实际上救了他的命。我不知道是否有哪一小时他没有想到这件事，以及他对发生的事情感到后悔。
In 1946, Burroughs met Joan Vollmer through Ginsberg.
1946年，伯勒斯通过金斯堡认识了琼·沃尔默（Joan Vollmer）。
Jack and I decided that Joan and Bill would make a great couple, that they were a match for each other, fit for each other, equally tuned and equally witty and equally intelligent, equally well read.
杰克和我断定琼和比尔会是一对绝配，他们彼此契合，不仅体型合适，而且同样默契、同样机智、同样聪明、同样博学。
It wasn't uncommon for gay men to marry women then.
那时同性恋男人娶女人并不罕见。
One time, she said, "Well, you're supposed to be a faggot, but you're as good as a pimp in bed." Well, I thought this was nonsense, and I still do.
有一次，她说：“好吧，你应该是个同性恋，但在床上你和皮条客一样好。”好吧，我认为这是胡说八道，现在也这么认为。
Joan was into Benzedrine. William was, of course, into heroin. In New York, he began dealing and stealing from drunks on the subway to finance his habit. Oliver Harris.
琼迷恋苯丙胺。威廉当然迷恋海洛因。在纽约，他开始倒卖毒品，并在地铁上偷醉汉的钱来资助他的习惯。奥利弗·哈里斯。
He went to Mexico City in late '49. It was the perfect place for Burroughs. He could be a queer. He could be a heroin addict. And it didn't matter because he could still flaunt the privileges of being an American abroad. And in a way, it did him a lot of good to unleash a dark side of him, which was crucial to his becoming a great writer.
他在1949年底去了墨西哥城。那是伯勒斯的完美之地。他可以做一个同性恋者。他可以做一个海洛因瘾君子。这无关紧要，因为他仍然可以挥霍作为海外美国人的特权。从某种程度上说，这对他大有裨益，释放了他黑暗的一面，这对他成为一名伟大的作家至关重要。
Joan was not making it with Bill, and I was a little irritated with him. Bill had been off with a young friend.
琼和比尔过得不顺心，我对他也有一点恼火。比尔一直和一个年轻朋友混在一起。
That day, I knew something awful was going to happen. I remember I was working down the street, and tears started just streaming down my face. Well, if that happens to you, watch out, baby.
那天，我知道会有什么可怕的事情发生。我记得我在街那边工作，眼泪就开始顺着脸流下来。好吧，如果这种事发生在你身上，小心了，宝贝。
The "something bad" happened at a party they went to that night. James Grauerholz.
那个“坏事”发生在那天晚上他们参加的一个聚会上。詹姆斯·格劳尔霍兹。
It appears to me clear that Joan was teasing him or taunting him. And there's the boyfriend, secretly, known to Joan. And evidently, he said, "We're going to move to the deep jungle in South America. That way, I'll kick my habit." And she apparently said something like, "How will we survive?" "Oh, I'll shoot wild boars and game." And she said, "Oh, with your marksmanship, we'll starve to death." And he says, "Oh, well why don't we show the boys what kind of a shot old Bill really is?"
在我看来很清楚，琼是在逗他或嘲弄他。那个男朋友秘密地存在，琼知道。显然，他说：“我们要搬到南美深处的丛林里去。那样，我就能戒掉毒瘾。”她显然说了类似这样的话：“我们怎么生存？”“哦，我会猎杀野猪和猎物。”她说：“哦，就凭你的枪法，我们会饿死的。”他说：“哦，那为什么我们不给这些家伙展示一下老比尔到底枪法如何呢？”
Then I said to Joan, it's about time for our William Tell act. And she put a glass on her head. I fired the shot. The glass hadn't been touched. Joan started sliding down towards the floor. Then Marcus said-- walked over and took one look at her. He said, "Billy, your bullet just hit her forehead." I said, "Oh my god."
然后我对琼说，该到我们表演“威廉·泰尔”的时候了。她把一个杯子放在头上。我开了那一枪。杯子没被碰到。琼开始滑向地板。然后马库斯说——走过去看了一眼。“比利，你的子弹刚才击中她的前额了。”我说：“噢，上帝啊。”
Had you done the William Tell thing before?
你以前做过“威廉·泰尔”表演吗？
Never. Just an absolute piece of insanity.
从来没有。绝对是一场疯狂的行径。
When I first heard about it way back when, the cynical view, well of course, what a great place to do it. You get away with it down there. But upon reflection, I would say this. When you've been drinking, drugging, or doping, there's something that kicks in that involves a disregard for human life. Yes, there sure is.
当我很久以前第一次听说这件事时，那种愤世嫉俗的观点是：好吧，那是做这件事的好地方。你在那里可以逃脱惩罚。但经过反思，我会说这个：当你酗酒、吸毒、嗑药时，某种涉及漠视人命的东西就会接管。是的，确实如此。
He called it ugly spirit, or whatever. And so it may lead your hand in a bad way. Do I think that he was in any way consciously thinking at that moment, "Well, this is a good chance. Maybe I'll miss." No. No, no, no, no, no, no. Not this person.
他称之为丑陋的精神，或者随便什么。所以它可能会以糟糕的方式引导你的手。我是否认为他在那一刻有意识地想：“好吧，这是一个好机会。也许我会射偏？”不。不，不，不，不，不，不。不是这个人。
Will Self has an opinion.
威尔·塞尔夫有他的观点。
Well, Burroughs murdered his wife. And that's not necessarily a fashionable or accepted view. When I wrote a new introduction to the Penguin Modern Classic of Junkie, I had a very close look at it again. I had a cold case investigation. And I simply do not think you can rule out the very strong possibility, or indeed likelihood, that there was some element of intentionality involved in him aiming a loaded gun at his wife's head when she had a shot glass on top of it, a gun that he knew to be inaccurate.
嗯，伯勒斯谋杀了他的妻子。这未必是一个时髦或被接受的观点。当我为企鹅现代经典版的《瘾君子》写新序时，我又仔细看了一遍。我进行了一次冷案调查。我根本不认为你能排除一种可能性，甚至说是很有可能，即当他把一把他知道不准的、上了膛的枪瞄准他妻子头上顶着的酒杯时，其中包含某种意图。
Either way, the apologists for Burroughs who say it was a dreadful accident and so forth are just like the apologists for Burroughs that there are in every area. And what we call apologists in the addiction world are enablers. And I think that enabling somebody to escape the reality of their homicidal actions is probably the worst kind of enabling you can engage in. Enabling his addiction is almost besides the point.
无论如何，那些为伯勒斯辩护说是可怕事故等等的人，就像每个领域里那些为伯勒斯辩护的人一样。我们称之为成瘾世界里的辩护者，实际上是帮凶。我认为帮助某人逃避其杀人行为的现实，可能是你所能参与的最恶劣的助纣为虐。帮助他的成瘾行为几乎都算不上什么重点了。
Burroughs wrote Queer while he was awaiting trial. In the introduction, he wrote, "I am forced to the appalling conclusion that I would never have become a writer but for Joan's death. The death of Joan brought me into contact with the invader, the ugly spirit, and maneuvered me into a lifelong struggle in which I had no choice except to write my way out."
伯勒斯在候审期间写了《同性恋者》。他在引言中写道：“我被迫得出一个惊人的结论：如果不是琼的死，我永远不会成为一名作家。琼的死亡让我接触到了入侵者，那个丑陋的精神，并迫使我进入了一场终生的挣扎，我别无选择，只能通过写作来解脱。”
When he talked about writing his way out of it, I think that in order for his recognition as a writer to exceed his notoriety as an uxoricide, he had to become a really good writer. That's what I mean by write his way out of it.
当他谈到通过写作来解脱时，我认为为了让人们认可他作为作家的身份超过他作为杀妻者的恶名，他必须成为一名非常优秀的作家。这就是我所说的“通过写作来解脱”的意思。
Well, I'd rather have the woman than the books. I mean, I think that's-- the artistic defense only really cuts any ice with the kind of enablers.
嗯，我宁愿要那个女人而不是书。我的意思是，我认为这……艺术上的辩护只有在那种帮凶面前才行得通。
All right. I'm going to take a break here. Take 5 or 10 minutes, and I'll be back. You can cut up the sentences or put them all together. Cut up. Cut up. Cut up. Cut up. Cut up project. Cut up. Cut up. Cut up. Cut up project. Cut up. Cut up montage.
好了。我要在这里休息一下。休息5到10分钟，我就会回来。你可以把句子剪开，或者把它们拼在一起。剪接。剪接。剪接。剪接。剪接计划。剪接。剪接。剪接。剪接计划。剪接。剪接蒙太奇。
Iggy, what do you think? I don't know what that is.
伊基，你怎么看？我不知道那是什么。
Cut ups after the break. Yes, you are still listening to This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. That is in a minute when our program continues.
休息过后讲剪接。是的，你依然在收听来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。节目会在一分钟后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Burroughs 101. This week, the writer William Burroughs would've been 101 years old. He died in 1997 at the age of 83. We are marking the birthday with this great documentary made for BBC Radio Four a year ago on his 100th birthday. Iggy Pop narrates. We pick up with Cut Ups.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目主题是：伯勒斯101。本周，作家威廉·伯勒斯本应101岁了。他于1997年去世，享年83岁。我们用这档为了BBC广播四台一年前在他100周年诞辰制作的伟大纪录片来纪念他。伊基·波普担任旁白。我们接着谈“剪接法”。
So can you tell me just what do you make of the cut up method?
那你能不能告诉我，你对“剪接法”到底怎么看？
How different is the cut up method really from what they used to call the magic eight ball? Do you know what that is? Or a Ouija board. It's a Ouija board for art people, is what it is. Language is a virus. Language is a virus. Virus is a language human scummery control is a virus.
“剪接法”和他们过去常说的“魔力8号球”（Magic 8-Ball）到底有什么不同？你知道那是什么吗？或者通灵板。它是给艺术人士准备的通灵板，就是这样。语言是病毒。语言是病毒。病毒是语言人类人渣控制是病毒。
Language control the virus. Language is a virus. Power and the things that we want to express using a language are not as interesting, as useful, or as dynamic as things that the language could say itself, if only you would let the language talk. The pretenses don't have much weight if you just give them a little push. But that was what I took the cut up to be, basically.
语言控制病毒。语言是病毒。权力和我们想要用语言表达的东西，并没有语言本身如果能说出来（只要你愿意让语言自己说话）所能表达的东西那么有趣、有用或充满活力。如果你稍微推它一下，那些虚伪的说辞就没什么分量了。但基本上，这就是我认为的“剪接法”。
Brion Gysin was living with William Burroughs at the time in the Beat Hotel in Paris.
布里恩·基辛（Brion Gysin）当时和威廉·伯勒斯住在巴黎的“垮掉派旅馆”。
One way Burroughs would describe him as "the only man I ever respected."
伯勒斯曾以某种方式称他是“我唯一尊重过的人”。
It's while he was doing his artwork that he discovered the cut up.
正是在他创作艺术品时，他发现了“剪接法”。
It occurred because I had a number of sheets of newspaper, and I took a Stanley blade and cut through them, and little bits and pieces looked so amusing to me that I started jiggling them around as one would in a collage.
这是因为我有几张报纸，我拿了一把美工刀切开它们，这些细小的碎片看起来非常有趣，我就开始像拼贴画那样把它们来回摆弄。
And he showed it to William Burroughs, and Burroughs immediately started using that technique.
他把它给威廉·伯勒斯看，伯勒斯立即开始使用这种技术。
Cut up. Cut up. Cut up. Cut up. Cut up created a new way of writing a novel. To help explain, we'll need a true Burroughs obsessive.
剪接。剪接。剪接。剪接。剪接创造了一种小说写作的新方法。为了解释清楚，我们需要一个真正的伯勒斯狂热者。
When I see Naked Lunch in a charity shop or a junk shop on the shelf, I don't want it to be there on its own. I just want to bring it home to daddy.
当我在慈善商店或旧货店的书架上看到《裸体午餐》时，我不希望它独自在那里。我只想把它带回家给爸爸。
Burroughsian, Ian MacFayden.
伯勒斯研究者，伊恩·麦克法登（Ian MacFayden）。
The cut up books contain within themselves the descriptions of the methods of their own creation.
剪接书籍本身就包含了它们自身创作方法的描述。
This is a technique. And like any technique, it will of course be useful to some writers and not to others.
这是一种技术。和任何技术一样，它对某些作家有用，对另一些则不然。
What is produced is uncanny. You read through it. You read underneath it. You get the back of the mask.
产出的东西是不可思议的。你从头读到尾。你从底下读。你看到了面具的背面。
These colorless sheets are empty. You ever existed at all. Goodbye to William.
这些无色的纸页是空的。你曾真正存在过。再见，威廉。
He used the cut up technique as a way of examining the media.
他把“剪接法”作为审视媒体的一种方式。
Then police keep all boardroom reports, and we are not allowed to proffer the disaster accounts.
警察保留所有董事会报告，我们不被允许展示灾难账户。
Discourses of the police, of government, of authority, but also the gibbering voice inside each of us.
警察、政府、权威的论述，但也包括我们每个人内心那个唠叨的声音。
Oh my god, show them how ugly the ugly American can be.
噢天哪，向他们展示那个丑陋的美国人能有多丑陋。
Which frustrated Burroughs throughout his life.
这让伯勒斯一生都感到沮丧。
Me, I am looking around. And the more I look, the less I like what I see.
我，我正四处张望。看得越多，我对所见的东西就越不喜欢。
Burroughs wrote The Soft Machine , The Ticket That Exploded, and Nova Express using cut up.
伯勒斯用“剪接法”写了《软机器》、《爆炸的票据》和《新星快车》。
It's not just the writing which was well known.
不仅仅是写作，这在当时很有名。
Oliver Harris.
奥利弗·哈里斯。
It was the photo montages, the tapes, the artwork. Rather than cut up being a dead end, it was incredibly-- it proliferated, overran expectations and possibilities.
还有照片蒙太奇、录音带、艺术作品。“剪接法”并非死胡同，它令人难以置信地增殖，超出了预期和可能性。
Now, here are some tapes which Brion made with all the technical facilities of the BBC in London. And they show, I think, what can be done with the human voice and one phrase.
现在，这里有一些布里恩用伦敦BBC所有技术设施制作的录音带。我认为，它们展示了用人声和一个短语可以做到什么。
All actors. Calling all-- calling all reactive agents. Calling all active agents re. Calling all active agents re. Calling all active re agents. Calling. All agents reactive. Calling all re agents active.
全员行动。呼叫所有——呼叫所有反应剂。呼叫所有活性剂。呼叫所有活性反应剂。呼叫。所有反应剂。呼叫所有活性反应剂。
I'm also working on a short film with Mr. Anthony Balch, Towers, Open Fire.
我也正在和托尼·巴尔奇（Anthony Balch）先生合作一部短片，《塔楼，开火》（Towers, Open Fire）。
Who are you?
你是谁？
I'm Bill, who are you?
我是比尔，你是谁？
I'm Tony. Where are you, Bill?
我是托尼。你在哪，比尔？
In a 1920 movie, Tony. Where are you?
在1920年的电影里，托尼。你在哪？
I'm in London.
我在伦敦。
The total taste is here. Have a happy-- have a happ--
总体的味道就在这里。祝你快乐——祝你快——
Is this machine recording? Is this machine recording? Is this machine recording?
这台机器在录音吗？这台机器在录音吗？这台机器在录音吗？
Johnson, addressing a meeting of editorial cartoonists of the White House, once held three maids at gunpoint and proceeded to ransack the apartment.
约翰逊在白宫向政治漫画家会议致辞时，曾持枪扣押了三名女佣，并着手洗劫了公寓。
The cut up project was, in Burroughs' own terms, a disastrous success in the sense that it was impossible. But they have something which is ferocious about them, and yet very funny. They're experimental. They're obscene. They're political. They're spiritual, a great call to arms against the 1%, who, in his view, were screwing the planet.
“剪接计划”用伯勒斯自己的话说是“灾难性的成功”，因为它在某种意义上是不可能的。但它们有一种凶猛的东西，而且非常有幽默感。它们是实验性的。它们是淫秽的。它们是政治性的。它们是精神性的，是对那1%人的伟大号角——在他看来，那些人正在摧毁这个星球。
With the '60s hippies transforming into '70s punks, the Burroughs effect multiplied.
随着60年代嬉皮士转变为70年代朋克，伯勒斯效应成倍增加。
Why do you think the punks found such an affinity for Burroughs?
你认为为什么朋克会对伯勒斯产生共鸣？
There's this undercurrent of, all this shit is a bunch of shit. You people are a bunch of shit. I don't have to respect the shit out of your-- a disrespect.
有一种潜流：这一切狗屎都是一堆狗屎。你们这些人就是一堆狗屎。我不必尊重你们的狗屎——一种不敬。
This is the what I do cut ups. I don't know if it's like the way Brion Gysin does his or Burroughs does his. I don't know. But this is the way I do it.
这就是我做剪接的方式。我不知道这是否像布里恩·基辛或伯勒斯做的那样。我不知道。但这确实是我做的方式。
David Bowie.
大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie）。
What I've used it for more than anything else is igniting anything that might be in my imagination. And you can often come up with very interesting attitudes to look into.
我用它最多的地方是激发想象力中可能存在的任何东西。你经常可以找到非常有意思的角度去审视。
Burroughs is now affecting everyone, all the big names. Musicians, artists, hipsters, they all love him. And for once, it's back home in America. That's my swift cover voice.
伯勒斯现在影响着所有人，所有大人物。音乐家、艺术家、时髦人士，他们都爱他。而且难得的是，这回是在美国的家乡。这是我的斯威夫特封面配音。
It was a wonderful time. Don't forget, we just got rid of Nixon.
那是一段美好的时光。别忘了，我们刚除掉了尼克松。
New York City, 1974.
纽约市，1974年。
It was a whole rebirth of this sensibility because the Nixon administration had tried really hard and quite effectively to destroy the counterculture. And so Burroughs' return was almost seen as the king returns to take his throne now that the evil king has fallen. Burroughs was the king of the underground.
那是这种感受力的一次新生，因为尼克松政府曾非常努力且相当有效地试图摧毁反文化。所以伯勒斯的回归几乎被视为国王回归，夺回他的王位，现在邪恶的国王已经倒台了。伯勒斯是地下的国王。
Victor Bockris was then a journalist and close associate of Andy Warhol and Burroughs.
维克多·博克里斯当时是一名记者，也是安迪·沃霍尔（Andy Warhol）和伯勒斯的亲密伙伴。
I remember a great scene at the St. Mark's Poetry Project. Patti Smith on stage in '74 finishing a reading by saying, "Guess who moved back to New York? William Burroughs. Isn't that great?" And I thought at that moment, "How wonderful." Because this new, vibrant movement of punk is not going to try and kill its fathers, but it's going to actually welcome them and salute them on their way to their own success.
我记得圣马克诗歌计划（St. Mark's Poetry Project）有一个很棒的场面。帕蒂·史密斯（Patti Smith）在74年的舞台上结束朗诵时说：“猜猜谁搬回纽约了？威廉·伯勒斯。那不是很棒吗？”那一刻我想：“多么美妙。”因为这股新兴的、充满活力的朋克运动，不会试图去杀死它们的祖先，而是会真正欢迎他们，并向他们在走向自身成功的路上致敬。
Not long after he settled in New York, William met the most important person in his late American career, James Grauerholz. James was 21. Burroughs was 60.
在他在纽约定居后不久，威廉遇到了他在美国晚期生涯中最重要的人，詹姆斯·格劳尔霍兹。詹姆斯21岁。伯勒斯60岁。
So James had come to offer his services to me as a secretary.
所以詹姆斯来向我提供服务，担任秘书。
Ginsberg.
金斯堡。
And I was hoping lover because he was kind of cute. He was 21, 20. And Bill had just come back, and I was worried about Bill getting straight. So I said, OK, if you want to be my secretary, the first thing to do is go down and see Burroughs.
我当时希望是情人，因为他长得挺可爱的。他当时21岁，20岁。比尔刚回来，我担心比尔会变回“直男”。所以我说：好的，如果你想当我的秘书，第一件事就是去见伯勒斯。
I went up and met him. We had some drinks, and within a week or so, he invited me to move in with him. And I did roommate with him and sleep with him for about six weeks. And then I met someone closer to my own age whom I moved in with. I told William, if we can be friends, I think we can be friends for life. Little did I know.
我去了那里见他。我们喝了点酒，一周之内他就邀请我搬去和他住。我做了他的室友，和他睡了大约六周。然后我遇到了一个和我年纪相仿的人，我就搬去和那个人住了。我告诉威廉，如果我们能做朋友，我想我们可以做一辈子的朋友。我当时万万没想到。
James was William's manager for the rest of his life.
詹姆斯在他余生里一直担任威廉的经纪人。
I was his reader, his audience, the person who couldn't wait to see what he had written, to go over it with him, to discuss it with him, to bring him more things to write the next part of it. I was the one who cared what he had spent the day doing.
我是他的读者，他的听众，那个迫不及待想看他写了什么、和他一起过目、和他讨论、为他带来更多东西去写下一部分的人。我是那个关心他每天都在做什么的人。
Grauerholz organized public readings for Burroughs. The young punks crowded in to see their long lost crazy uncle. It all climaxed with the Nova Convention.
格劳尔霍兹为伯勒斯组织了公开朗诵会。年轻的朋克们蜂拥而至，想要见见他们失散多年的疯狂叔叔。这一切在“新星大会”（Nova Convention）达到了高潮。
This is the Nova Convention. Welcome to the Nova Convention. This is a test.
这就是新星大会。欢迎来到新星大会。这是一次测试。
The Nova Convention was a very important event in New York. It was the first time which was a public meeting where all the elements of the Beat punk generation came together.
新星大会是纽约非常重要的活动。这是“垮掉派”和朋克一代所有元素首次汇聚在一起的公共会议。
LadiesFRANK and gentlemen, William Burroughs.
女士们、先生们，威廉·伯勒斯。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
This is the Space Age, and we are here to go. Only those who are willing to leave everything they've ever known in time need apply.
这是太空时代，我们正要出发。只有那些愿意放弃他们在时间中曾经知道的一切的人，才需要报名。
And the people who organized it tried to invite a number of artists from different mediums, such as Patti Smith. Keith Richards was supposed to be involved. Frank Zappa came to it. All sorts of people came.
组织者试图邀请不同媒介的艺术家，比如帕蒂·史密斯。基思·理查兹（Keith Richards）本应参加。弗兰克·扎帕（Frank Zappa）也来了。各色人等都来了。
Just setting up for the great Frank Zappa.
正在为伟大的弗兰克·扎帕做准备。
Did I ever tell you about the man who taught his asshole to talk?
我有没有告诉过你那个教他的屁股说话的男人的故事？
William was one of the first people that ever branded himself, before there was such a word as that, by how he looked, how he talked, how he baited people. He was almost predictable in his macabre sense of humor. But it wasn't a lie. William really was like that. I mean, I think he was like that when nobody was there too. I don't think it was an act. But at the same time, he lent himself very well to fame.
威廉是第一批真正把自己当品牌的人之一——在还没这个词的时候——他通过自己的外表、谈吐以及逗弄人们的方式做到了。他在阴森的幽默感方面几乎是可预测的。但这并不是谎言。威廉确实就是那样的人。我的意思是，我觉得没人在场的时候他也是那样。我不觉得那是演戏。但与此同时，他非常适合成名。
In 1981, William appeared on Saturday Night Live , graciously introduced by the actress Lauren Hutton.
1981年，威廉出现在《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live）上，由女演员劳伦·赫顿（Lauren Hutton）优雅地介绍出场。
I'm very pleased tonight to introduce a man who, in my opinion, is the greatest living writer in America. In his first television appearance ever, here is Mr. William Burroughs.
今晚我很高兴介绍一位在我看来是美国最伟大的在世作家。在他首次电视亮相中，请出威廉·伯勒斯先生。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
Doctor Benway ships doctor drunkenly added two inches to a four inch incision with one stroke of his scalpel. "Perhaps the appendix is already out, doctor," the nurse said, peering dubiously over his shoulder. I saw a little scar. The appendix out? I'm taking the appendix out. What do you think I'm doing here? He lifts the abdominal wall and searches along the incision, dropping ashes from his cigarette.
本韦医生（Doctor Benway）醉醺醺地用手术刀一挥，给四英寸的切口多加了两英寸。“也许阑尾已经摘除了，医生，”护士怀疑地在他肩后窥视。“我看见了一道小疤痕。阑尾摘除了？我正在摘除阑尾。你以为我在做什么？”他提起腹壁，在切口处搜索，弹掉香烟上的烟灰。
100 million views, laughter, respect, a literary halo.
1亿次浏览、笑声、尊重、文学光环。
We're getting into the cat section. It's almost like, all right, we got to the point where Burroughs is at his height. It's almost like we should stop there, but we're not.
我们要进入猫的部分了。这简直就像，好了，我们已经到了伯勒斯处于巅峰的状态。这简直像我们应该停在那里，但我们没有。
Oh, what haven't we covered yet? Hate. Cats.
噢，我们还没讲什么？仇恨。猫。
Right. We're getting into the cat section now. And the good news is, it's the last section.
对。我们要进入猫的部分了。好消息是，这是最后一部分。
Evidence indicates that cats were first tamed in Egypt. The Egyptians stored grain, which attracted rodents, which attracted cats. I postulate that cats started as psychic companions, as familiars, and have never deviated from this function.
证据显示猫最初是在埃及被驯化的。埃及人储存粮食，引来啮齿动物，进而引来猫。我推测猫最初是作为精神伴侣、作为灵媒出现的，并且从未偏离过这一功能。
Do you like cats?
你喜欢猫吗？
I do like cats. I feed so many cats that I'm a little bit pissed off at them right now because I spend a lot of time and money feeding them all the time. What they do, the way they get me to feed them, and my wife too-- I feed them here and in the islands. They just come and stare at you.
我确实喜欢猫。我喂的猫太多了，以至于我现在对它们有点生气，因为我花了很多时间和钱一直在喂它们。它们所做的事、它们让我喂它们的方式，以及我妻子的方式——我在这里和岛上都喂它们。它们就走过来盯着你看。
I find this desperate attempt to win a human protector deeply moving. The cat does not offer services. The cat offers itself.
我发现这种试图赢得人类保护者的绝望尝试深深打动了我。猫不提供服务。猫提供它们自己。
He has this line where he just says, cats give you themselves.
他有这样一句台词，他说猫把它们自己交给你。
Yeah, I have that bit in there.
是的，那段内容我有。
That's a deep line. In one of his last books, The Cat Inside , William writes about some of the many cats he owned, like Ruskie, Ginger, and Calico. Burroughs' young lover Marcus visited him.
那是一句深刻的话。在他最后几本书之一《猫在里面》（The Cat Inside）中，威廉写到了他拥有的许多猫，比如拉斯基（Ruskie）、姜黄（Ginger）和花猫（Calico）。伯勒斯的年轻爱人马库斯拜访了他。
I think he had at least six cats while I was there. And he had this one cat that would really pretty much hug you. It would stand up on your-- I've never seen a cat do this. If you're sitting on the sofa, it would stand up on its hind legs on your lap and put a paw, its front paws, one on either side of your head and just look right at you and press its head in close to you. It was the damnedest thing.
我想我在那儿时他至少有六只猫。他有一只猫，真的会紧紧拥抱你。它会站起来……我从没见过猫这么做。如果你坐在沙发上，它会后腿直立在你的膝盖上，把爪子——它的前爪，放在你头部的两侧，就这样盯着你，把头贴在你身上。那真是最不可思议的事。
And William just loved his cats. I mean, he loved his cats so much. And I'm not trying to-- he loved people, too. But I think it was a much more scary and fraught and frightening thing for him.
威廉真的非常爱他的猫。我的意思是，他非常爱他的猫。我不是想说……他也爱人。但我认为这对他来说是一件更令人恐惧、忧虑和惊恐的事。
Toward the end of his life, Burroughs became more concerned about the environment. It was like his childhood in Saint Louis was fading away, the old beautiful Midwestern America. William could feel the loss.
在他生命后期，伯勒斯开始更多地关注环境。这就像他在圣路易斯的童年正在消逝，那种古老、美丽的美国中西部。威廉能感受到这种丧失。
The magical medium is being bulldozed away. No more green reindeer in Forest Park. The angels are leaving all of the alcoves everywhere as the forests fall to make way for motels and Hiltons and McDonald's. The whole magic universe is dying. The rain forests of Borneo and South America are going to make way for what?
神奇的媒介正在被推土机铲平。森林公园里再也没有绿色的驯鹿了。随着森林倒下，让位给汽车旅馆、希尔顿酒店和麦当劳，天使们正在离开各处的壁龛。整个魔法宇宙正在死去。婆罗洲和南美的雨林正在消失，为的是什么？
I think he was a deeply sad person, deeply, deeply, deeply, deeply sad person. So I think William did have this deep, deep, deep skepticism about people being able to connect. And I think specifically, people being able to connect with him.
我觉得他是一个非常悲伤的人，极其、极其、极其、极其悲伤的人。所以我认为威廉对人们建立联系的能力有着极深、极深、极深的怀疑。我特指人们与他建立联系的能力。
There must have been a split between the cats who accepted domestication and those who did not.
在接受驯化的猫和未接受驯化的猫之间一定存在某种分歧。
One day, one of his closest friends, Tom Peschio, went to see him at dinnertime, and William was having a coughing fit and had been having chest pains. And within a few minutes, Tom had convinced him to let Tom call 9-1-1, and me. He went to the hospital. He was not conversing. And then they got him stabilized. His eyes were open. He seemed to hear. But he wasn't speaking.
有一天，他最亲密的朋友之一汤姆·佩肖（Tom Peschio）在晚餐时间去看他，威廉正发作咳嗽，而且胸口一直疼痛。几分钟内，汤姆就说服了他，让他打电话给911，还通知了我。他去了医院。他没有说话。然后他们稳定了他的状况。他眼睛睁着。他似乎听到了。但他没说话。
William had made a no extraordinary measures instruction. In other words, I'm going to say do not resuscitate. And William simply took his last breath. And that is how he died.
威廉曾留下过“不采取非常措施”的指示。换句话说，我会说“不要复苏”。威廉就这样呼出了最后一口气。他就是这样去世的。
He was gentlemanly. He was an old school gentleman. He had manners. He loved to have friends around him. He loved to carry on. He loved to meet new people. He loved his fans. In the media, there is this other stereotypical presentation of who William Burroughs was, the guy in a three piece suit with a needle in his arm. But that's not the William I saw. That wasn't him. He was a very complex human.
他很有绅士风度。他是一位老派绅士。他有礼貌。他喜欢朋友环绕。他喜欢交谈。他喜欢结识新朋友。他爱他的粉丝。在媒体中，对威廉·伯勒斯有另一种刻板印象的呈现：那个穿着三件套西装、手臂上扎着针的人。但这并不是我看到的威廉。那不是他。他是一个非常复杂的人。
But none of this biographical stuff is of any interest apart from the actual writing. And what worries me in the centenary year is that everybody's talking about how they met Bill, and Bill said this, and Bill said that. Actually, no. I mean, people should really read the books.
但这所有的传记内容除了实际作品外毫无兴趣可言。在百年纪念年，让我担心的是每个人都在谈论他们如何遇见比尔，比尔说了这个，比尔说了那个。实际上，不。我的意思是，人们真的应该去读他的书。
He had this image, a kind of cold, blue, almost ray-like, almost alien image. And of course, he could be like that. He was like that in performances in public. It was his persona. But the real William Burroughs was just a wonderful gentleman and a great artist and a great friend. I miss him very much. I'm really glad to talk about him. It means a lot to me.
他有一种形象，一种寒冷的、蓝色的、几乎像射线一样、几乎像外星人一样的形象。当然，他可以是那样。他在公共表演中就是那样。那是他的人设。但真正的威廉·伯勒斯只是一位出色的绅士、一位伟大的艺术家、一位伟大的朋友。我非常想念他。谈论他对我意义重大。
I miss him. I miss him. I miss him bad.
我想念他。我想念他。我非常想念他。
Just a wonderful gentleman.
只是一位出色的绅士。
Gentleman.
绅士。
Centenary year.
百年纪念年。
I miss him.
我想念他。
Human.
人类。
Means a lot to me.
意义重大。
William talks to me every day.
威廉每天都和我对话。
Alien image.
外星人形象。
I miss him.
我想念他。
Read the books.
阅读他的书。
Old school.
老派。
Persona.
人设。
With a needle in his arm.
手臂上扎着针。
I miss him bad.
我非常想念他。
What do you think the last words of the program should be? What's your final sum up of Burroughs?
你认为节目最后的话应该是什么？你对伯勒斯的总结是什么？
This wonderful American man of a certain generation did his best to shoulder the burden of intelligence and sensitivity and to deal with his pain. That's what I would say.
这位杰出的美国男人，在那个特定的一代，尽其所能承担了智慧和敏感的重担，并处理了他的痛苦。我会这么说。
Thanks, Iggy.
谢谢，伊基。
All right, man. Awesome. As long as you're satisfied and--
好了，伙计。棒极了。只要你满意，并且——
I am, man.
我满意了，伙计。
I'm still in one piece, fair enough.
我还完整，这就够了。
You laid down a lot of stuff there.
你在这儿讲了很多内容。
All right.
好。
Burroughs 101 was presented by Iggy Pop. And when I say presented, I mean he narrated the show. The producer was Colin McNulty, executive producer Kevin Dawson. It was independently produced for BBC Radio Four by Whistle Down Productions. You can find out about other programs they've made at whistledown.net.
《伯勒斯101》由伊基·波普呈现。当我说是呈现时，我的意思是他是节目的旁白。制作人是科林·麦克纳尔蒂，执行制作人凯文·道森（Kevin Dawson）。它是由Whistle Down Productions为BBC广播四台独立制作的。你可以在whistledown.net了解他们制作的其他节目。
This American Life is produced by Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Simon Adler. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon, our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Elena Baker scouts stories for our show. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Co-founder. Thanks, co-founder.
《美国生活》的制作人包括肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作协助来自西蒙·阿德勒（Simon Adler）。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）负责我们的网站。埃琳娜·贝克（Elena Baker）为我们的节目搜寻故事。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX递送给公共广播电台。一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人，先生，联合创始人。谢谢，联合创始人。
You're as good as a pimp in bed.
你在床上和皮条客一样好。
Co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia.
联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。
Pimp.
皮条客。
Torey, thank you so much.
托雷，非常感谢。
In bed.
在床上。
I'm Ira Glack-- I'm Ira. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week. Back, back, back, back. Ira Glass. Stories. More. This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉——我是艾拉。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见。再见，再见，再见，再见。艾拉·格拉斯。故事。更多。《美国生活》。
In bed.
在床上。